thank you um prime minister look we know
to expect to reassuring uh performance
from you but in the real world you can't
get a train you can't get a doctor's
appointment nurses are going to food
banks and when you do dial 999 you can't
be sure that an ambulance is going to
get there in time to save your loved one
that's the reality of Britain in 2023
and now you're here giving people more
promises about how you might change the
country that they've heard many times
before during 13 years of conservative
rule my question really is why should
the public believe you're any different
to any of your predecessors
I think the country have seen me
performing the job before through really
difficult times they saw me as
Chancellor during covid in fact most of
them probably didn't know who I was
until I appeared on that press
conference on their TV screens and I'm
proud of the record that I have as
Chancellor I think we moved at enormous
speed and with competence to actually
deliver interventions that made a
difference to people's lives that saved
their jobs Protected Their businesses
and so people can trust that when I say
I'm going to do something I am going to
do it and the second thing is I've been
very clear as I said today unambiguous
made five very simple promises the
country's priorities are my priorities I
want to be held account for their mum
there's no ambiguity about them there's
no tricks people will know whether I'm
delivering on these things and I'm
confident that we can I really am and
you talk about the record you know
actually I'm not going to say the NHS
wasn't under any pressure before covert
of course it was but that you know there
were places where things were really
improving and you look at ambulance
times for example category to we are
just about at Target before covid hit
and it's undeniable though that kovid
has had an impact I talked about the
fact that elective surgery was paused
during covert you can look at the same
with cancer referrals they were down by
a third or two-thirds during covid and
now obviously there are far more than
normal right so that's why that's not
performing as well as we would like it
to but it's improving so look covert has
had an impact it's not an excuse this is
one of my five promises people know what
I did for them during covert as
Chancellor and that's why I'm here today
being very clear about what I'm going to
deliver for them in the country as prime
minister I'm very confident we can do
that but ultimately people will hold me
to account for doing so